when did it become so embarrassing to
just be a comedian for a living well
that's the that's the Hedberg joke what
is when like you come to La as a
comedian like oh you're a comedian do
you act yeah do you write oh you're a
chef do you
farm nothing to do with the thing that
I'm doing and yeah I'll get in my head
about like like comedians are superstars
now 15 years ago comedians were
comedians but they weren't celebrities
right right right right now it's like
people are doing basketball St like on
the rig don't you think a lot of the
people though that are doing B stadiums
aren't on traditional Network television
that we were all trying to get approval
of daddy daddy yeah yeah it's all like
the YouTube people but to look at
somebody like oh because you're not
playing a stadium you're not successful
as a comment like yeah yeah dude yeah
hey Andrew sches you